this Strait is called the bandab meaning
the Gate of Tears vessels have to go
through the passage to get to the SE
Canal which handles about 12% of World
Trade and is a major Maritime choke
point but this is also one of the most
dangerous shipping areas on the globe in
the months following the Hamas Israel
war a commercial ship was hijacked here
another was targeted by a drone here and
these circles represent other attacks by
militants on boats in the Strategic Zone
avoiding it means adding thousands of
nautical miles by traveling around the
cape at the bottom of Africa an
expensive and timec consuming Venture
instead some vessels are looking to
Boler security to avoid disruption in
the Red Sea and mitigate against delays
that could see consumer prices rise
here's
how recent attacks on Commercial vessels
in the key Waterway have been launched
by the houthis an iran-backed militant
group in Yemen the houthis are using
positions next to the B mandab to Target
Merchant vessels and what it says is a
response to the Hamas Israel war they
have attacked boats with missiles with
drones and in in one case actually
seized a seized a boat in a very
dramatic Heist this body cam footage
shows the moments armed militants land a
helicopter on the deck of a cargo ship
before storming into the bridge The
Vessel was traveling on the Red Sea a
vital passage for shipping Goods through
the sew Canal from Asia into Europe to
the rest of the world more than 20% of
all the containers that move around the
world by sea go through sez about 10% of
crude oil lots of cars chemicals
liquefied natural gas all sorts but the
attacks LED major shipping companies
including mask and Har Park Lloyd to
suspend operations in the area instead
they are sending ships via the Cape of
Good hope in South Africa however this
route is much longer and costs more in
fuel taking on average 43 days resulting
in higher prices for businesses the Red
Sea Roots by contrast takes 34 days in
any War or conflict involving a
involving countries with a coastline
shipping companies are faced with a
question do they want to keep on
operating in those Waters or not and
this is a dangerous industry at times
but some people risk The Gauntlet and
can be rewarded for doing so Merchant
ships traveling through the region on
both routes have faced danger before
this saudi-owned oil tanker was hijacked
far off the coast of Kenya by pirates in
2008 it came amid a Spate of other
attacks by Somali pirates complicating
Red Sea shipping lanes and forcing the
industry to bolster defenses vessels
constructed barbed wire fencing
dispersed water cannons and installed
high pitched acoustic devices others
even worked with floating arsenals where
Weaponry could be picked up on
rout but those defenses will be largely
useless against the attacks being
launched by the
houthis it's the first time that
Merchant vessels have been targeted by
anti-ship ballistic missiles according
to us officials some are taking
precautions to try and reduce the danger
of some for example are turning off um
the AIS signals those are trackers used
on vessels to be visible to each other
during navigation by turning them off
vessels are trying to remain undetected
others have changed their destination
signal to a message saying armed guards
on
board shipping companies are also
turning to security analysts for advice
on dealing with another new threat drin
attacks this is a revolution in nature
of war that played out UK Crane and is
now um at at playing the Red Sea as well
one possible measure is learning how to
spot drones as they're incoming early so
that a ship could then you know sail to
a to a safe location but for now one of
the safest ways for vessels to travel
through the Waterway is to lean on help
from Allied
militaries a us-led multinational task
force moov to the area in December to
escort vessels and shoot down
projectiles however attack
continued this footage released by the
Israeli military is set to show a houy
Target flying over the Red Sea us
officials said among the challenges to
striking houy targets is that many of
their weapons systems are mobile that's
leading to fears of widespread
disruption to trade flows that could
worsen inflation by boosting prices for
goods and
energy ultimately if it continues it
will lead to higher prices the ships
that for example move uh move containers
they've been tied up for longer on these
voyages so the shipping companies are
already charging more per day to Charter
out their boats to move containers and
that will feed through to Consumers that
there's no way that this gets absorbed
by the supply chain the US is looking at
different options to try and end the
trouble in the
Waterway one is a more forceful military
response measures that could take out uh
the houthi military capabilities at
their route another is diplomacy and you
know a lot of people say that ultimately
the best way to stop this becoming a
crisis is to diplomacy Saudi Arabia a
key us partner in the Middle East for
example is in talks with the houthis
about ending the Civil War in Yemen
haling attacks in the Red Sea and in
turn helping the world continue with
global trade could be another item on
the agenda during those
negotiations